so let's get right into michael bury how
about that i think michael bury's always
got a good thing to say that makes
people
uh think michael berry from big short
what page is it on page six let's get
right into it michael brewery
big short all right let's pull up a
picture of the infamous michael bury
let's pull up his picture
gotta love this guy i love him he's not
a freak he's a regular looking guy he's
a regular looking guy
big short investor michael bury is back
on twitter and warning of the biggest
market bubble in history this is a
market insider story
suggesting that his concerns about
rampant speculation only grew during
this
10-week hiatus from twitter people
always ask me what is going on in the
markets the investor tweeted it is
simple
greatest speculative bubble of all time
in all things by two orders of magnitude
flying pigs 360. the hashtag was likely
referenced to a famous saying in
investing bulls make money
bears make money but pigs get
slaughtered berry has
repeatedly told investors and they're
being too greedy speculated wildly
uh speculating wildly shouldering too
much risk and chasing
unrealistic return returns the scion
asset
management chief deleted his twitter
profile in april
after sounding alarm to tesla stock
which is short as well as gamestop
bitcoin dogecoin robinhood spacks
inflation and border stock market
broader stock market so having said that
tom do you agree with what michael bury
is saying i mean this is not a guy that
just throws comments like that out there
right you know i think he's correct on
on a couple axis and the question is
going to be is which
sectors pop right what sectors i don't
mean pop up which
are the the classic pop of the bubble
because
there are three factors right now
inflation is low but everybody's talking
about it going up you look at the number
of times it's mentioned in the media you
see all those charts people are talking
about inflation
interest rates are continued to be at
historic multi-year
lows and which makes debt cheap so
you've got three problems one i can get
all the capital i want
asset prices get inflated speculation
there we've already talked about people
taking uh the the millennials
and the z's taking their uh their checks
and open a robin hood account
rather than using it for anything or
paying their parents rent and so i i
think he's right you've got all these
things that are driving up speculation
in the market
because there's so much capital out
there debt is ridiculously cheap
and you know i think he's right the
question is going to be where does the
correction happen
does the correction happen in real
estate does a correction happen
in in energy you know where does a
correction happen and i
and right now you know my eyes are on
real estate because
what's happening in real estate there's
a really bad side of it that's happening
on rents
and so i think the government's got to
step up but i think he's right and so
what will be the pin that pops the
bubble
i don't know but i'll tell you i i think
he's right
what do you mean by rents it's off by
the way if you've got what do you mean
by rents
well what's happening right now is if
you take you know you you and me
maybe we buy a small house and we're
going to have it as a rental right now
if we pay 50 60 cash
you know we probably keep the rent at
some current market moderate
but right even at low interest rates
with debt
we look back and we do the math on it
and the rent needs to be five six seven
percent higher
than it was a year ago because the
underlying asset
cost us more to buy and there's a
payback model we're not trying to gouge
renters
it's just the payback on it so i'm yeah
i'm looking at rents that are being
driven
by housing prices it's interesting that
you bring up
rents and real estate because if you
actually look at essentially what
is named here he's talking about tesla
stock gamestop which
we all experienced the beginning of this
year and i interviewed
the founder of wall street bets who had
very strong opinions on everything that
was going on with gamestop
he names bitcoin he names obviously
dogecoin elon musk
a little uh friend right there robin
hood spax which we cover a lot
inflation which the fed just came out
and jerome powell had some
some words to share on inflation yeah
maybe i will maybe i will that's what
i'm thinking about and the broader stock
market so
he names all these asset classes like
you said could pop pop you know pop the
bubble
i think it's just interesting that you
he didn't name real estate but you
instinctively said well you know maybe
the real estate here because when was
where did michael berry
make his name for himself was when he
basically called the subprime mortgage
meltdown in 2008 he basically bet
against
america and if you ever saw the movie
with the big short with
right um brad pitt and uh yeah well
hollywood glamorized it but what he was
pointing out was there were bad
mortgages in bonds and there was
insurance on those bonds and that
combination was the classic line that
was in the big short
it says if this
the bond was the what was it if the bond
was the
you know was the match then the
insurance that was on the bond that was
20 to one insurance
was the nuclear warhead and it was um he
was right
yeah he was right he said there were
crap more than that if you're watching
this right now
i'm curious if you're watching this
right now how many of you your rent has
increased i just looked at an article
right now rents for single family homes
just saw the largest gains in 15 years
this is a june 15 story which is two
days and when they say gain like a stock
what they're really saying is the rent
increase yeah
yeah so single family rents were up 5.3
percent
year over year in april rising from a
2.4 increase in april
5.3 rent went up that means if i'm
paying two thousand dollars a month now
it's twenty one hundred dollars right
if i'm paying three thousand that's
twenty one thirty one fifty which
you may say that's not bigger that's a
single factor that's another two thirds
of a month that's that's
that may be not a lot to you remember
the guy that's making 50k is going to
see this
yeah that is the largest gain in nearly
15 years regionally by top 20
metropolitan markets rent gains were
highest in phoenix
and then uh a lower price of 70 percent
let's do super fast math on your example
pat
you said for people listening two
thousand dollars goes up five percent
there's 100
that's 1200 a year so now you're on your
way to adding almost a 13 month to that
rent you see that to the average person
so here's here's how that looks if you
go
let's just say they increase two
thousand dollars fifty bucks that's 1200
bucks a year
if a person is making fifty thousand
dollars a year what's 1200 to them
is that two percent that's two percent
right two point five percent two point
uh uh yeah two and a half percent of
their income
just went down that's pre-tax obviously
right that's pre-tax so even if i go
post tax that let's just say that's a
four percent decrease
i need a four percent range imagine you
go to your company
and you go to your company and they say
this year we're decreasing everybody's
salary by four percent
you may not feel it but you're going to
feel it right because for that middle
america low-income family so
uh and then it's not only this gas goes
up everything is pretty much going up so
you're only seeing
one aspect of expense people going to
see it on other places but
if again if you're watching this and
your went went up i'm curious
has anybody felt it anywhere uk one
person said their rent went up 55
in uk uh mark sesh just says my buddies
rent from went from 1360
to 1700 in mesa arizona
yeah anyways we're going to see what's
going to stay the 17th that's a big
number it's time to find a new apartment
uh he's also in mesa arizona where
there's high demand back to
michael bury uh is this someone you
would want to get his perspective on
valuetainment is this someone that you
we've spoken to michael brewery michael
berry doesn't want to do an interview
but if michael berry wants to do an
interview and we'll just do audio we
will all day have him on here
i would love to have him on no problem
uh because i think the guys
uh the guy's counsel and the way he sees
stuff
you're not necessarily a hundred percent
right
but you have to get perspective and to
me i think eventually
if you've been in this game for a while
like let me give you an example okay
sports can you see when it when when a
tights turn in when the team's about to
make a comeback
yeah literally last night philadelphia
versus atlanta that was ridiculous what
just happened was the philly was up 20
then they lose by seven
they're up 20 and 26 in the third
quarter with three minutes left
to the better the betters in las vegas
said there's a 99.7 percent chance
meltdown that philly's winning and they
lose it right but
you still notice them people are playing
sloppy people are getting nervous
they're missing free throws
michael bury is that guy in investments
you have to listen to what he has to say
it's that simple when he says that he's
got a point and i think if it does
happen
it is not going to be pretty here's the
only thing to be thinking about this is
just my thoughts on this on what to be
thinking about
is it fair to say every 10 years we have
a crash correct it's the first to say
every 10 years we have a crash
it's part of the cycle let's go back
last 10 years what was the biggest crash
in the last 10 years from 2011
to 2021 biggest crash obviously
you're right okay perfect go from 2001
to 2011 the biggest crash
2008 the great two thousand two thousand
seven yes
go 1991 to 2001 the
dot com boom the dot com bubble right
99. go
go 90 81 to 91. what 87
87 88 87 88 recession if we go
every decade there is a crash here's the
only differentiator here's the only
differentiator
so the only differentiator is if you
make 20-year runs you're not affected by
it
that's correct if you're making 20-year
investments
you're not affected by it you're only
affected by it
if your volatile game stops going to
make me a billionaire and i'm going to
make my money off dogecoin i'm only
if you're playing that speculative game
you
many are gonna get their tails handed to
them but if you're playing the long game
you may lose 30 of your portfolio you
may lose 20
of your portfolio long game you're going
to see the difference between day
trading and decade trading
right i mean day traders this is
literally goes back to his quote
where you know bulls make money bears
make money picks gets slaughtered
so if you're just all in on bitcoin all
in on dogecoin you think it's going to
the moon
you know there could be a crash landing
sometime soon yeah you know because you
would you like you like you say sorry to
cut you off this dog but you say about
valuetainment i'm on a 20-year run here
i'm doing this for 20 years so a video
you do today might pop it might get a
million views or
a video you do next week might crash but
you're in this for 20 years who gives a
[ __ ]
like things will happen yeah you know
you you look at it this way
so 529s are out there which is savings
exactly right so when bailey was younger
i left it in what's called
age and it was tiaa cref that was
managing it and
because they were the sponsor for
california every state's got a different
financial provider that does their 529.
so
when bailey was there i had on age age
synchronized risk which means when she's
in kindergarten the risk that they're
allowing to be
in the investments that are in there
automatically i don't make the decisions
i just say
i'll take the age so it's kind of like a
target date fund
correct that's exactly right finance
yeah so what what happened was
you know she lost 30 of her poor little
529 when she was four years old probably
how old was she
he's four years old okay yeah now it's
bounced back and that's right now now
it's back and it's
tripled since then bailey's a
millionaire no no she's not a
millionaire but she
she's not going to have student loans
for a bachelor's i'll tell you that's
great that's a great dad right there
no no her grades are insane go ahead tom
and then what i did was i
flipped the switch on age synchronized
risk when she was a freshman
because i was thinking about the traders
and maybe the synchronized risk with
their looking at the current market
and i moved it to you know you know
market index funds and
that which is another choice yeah the
age synchronized risk has been
more volatile and i'm like wow their age
synchronized risk
these are people are supposed to be
professionally managed target date funds
and even them pbd are you know what i'm
saying they're a little too crazy
but brooks fund i don't worry about it
because if it pops right now it's like
2008 for bailey and then
it's going to be back but i think that
even i'm seeing so i'm seeing in wall
street
just in the 529s i think there's more
you know optimism and riskiness even at
a time where they're supposed to be
managing it according to
a target date fund and what's your
advice to the young people out there are
just starting to have kids and they're
basically setting up these 529 plans
look it's the taxes are going up and so
if income taxes are going up there's
more reason
to live moderately and to get 529
protection for some dollars for your kid
and take the long view
take the long view yeah i mean listen
here's the point
you're working day to day you're going
to get crushed you're working long term
you're going to be all right if you're
going to be constantly emotional buying
selling buying selling buying selling
you're going to take a hit but the
reality part of it is take a look at ken
golden
from uh golden auctions this is a
collectible cards
auctions he just raised some money last
year do you know how much he sold last
month in cards
just last bloomberg contacted him to do
a story you know how much he saw last
month in collectible cards
what do you think he sold just last did
i tell you the number oh no what do you
think he sold
last month total collectible cards just
last month auctions
i'm gonna make a wild wild guess just
just remember like this guy was doing a
couple million dollars a month
then he went to 5 million then he had a
record-breaking month he did 10 million
what do you think he did last month
i'm going to say with all the capital
that's out there and everything that's
happened
did he touch a billion dollars billion
dollars a month no that's aggressive
hearts
i would say 50 million 100 million 50
million last month
but you know what 50 million is up from
a million though guys you know what 50
million is 50 million is 51 million
dollar cards
it's 100 500 000 cards
it's a thousand hundred thousand dollar
cards i don't think people write like th
50 million and you've got half a hundred
thousand times ten
is a million times another ten it's 10
million so 100
you're talking about the guy's selling
so much right now because people are
willing
to buy cards today they're not going
away right
but is that going to be the case if the
market tanks i don't know about that
long term are they still going to be
great investments non-duplicatable
assets will
always keep their value we need to add
non-duplicate all assets though
assets that's it what's it like to have
a calculator
in your brain to like to have a
calculator like you're literally like
you know i messed one of them up when i
said 50 million times 100 but you do
have a calculator up here i'm like let
me bust out my calculator
and get it you know you've got something
something going on up there
500 times 100 000 cards that's what i
was going to say it's 500 100 000. those
days to drive you nuts
but you're on the big run yeah if you're
on the long you have to like listen
you're building a business you have a
bad day you you had a bad sale day but
you busted your till
don't worry about it now here's the
thing if you had a bad sales day but you
didn't bust your tail
worry about it because habits are what
gets you destroyed long term
because you were listening you were
living easy and living assuming
isn't there a bigger story here a bigger
metaphor
for whether that's investing whether
it's relationships whether it's
health whether it's trading cards
whatever it is that
you're going to have good days and bad
days but overall if your perspective is
positive and you're here for the long
run
things are going to work out well
obviously if you work hard and you're
all right
sneezing on the truth if you if you do
your part yes
if you get emotional no if you're
constantly getting rattled
no if you can't see like what what'd you
say what happened
what did he say if you're constantly
what did the market do oh my gosh right
right right take it out
it's really agreeable this goes back to
your stoicism that you talked about last
week well you know no and also what he
talked about a minute ago about
what asset class are you playing in if
you're in a
if you're in a very risky sandbox
that doesn't have natural scarcity for
what's in there non-duplicable assets
with natural scarcity
real estate on the beach scarcity
right so it may crash and everything but
that's the part that's
the scarce stuff that will be in demand
is going to come back first and so
but if you're out there i'll give you an
example
if you're out there on gamestop and
you're just living with the guys on
reddit
on one stock there talking about retail
purchase of games at a time when games
are on the cloud
i think you're that is foolishly risky
because there's
nothing to come back when the party's
over you know what i will say if you're
under
gold cards if you're under 25 and you're
doing it
go at it if you're under 25 you're doing
it go at it you're going to learn
something
you're going to learn something listen i
was 25 and 49 000
in that you know what i did one time let
me tell you one of the dumbest things
i've ever done in my life you ready
is this the vegas gambling story this is
the dumbest thing i did in my life
i'm 25 years old 20 i'm 20
freddie chacon so this is what i'm 23
years old okay
uh uh i go to las vegas i'm trying to
say when i get my morgan stanley job i
got a 9-11 so it's a week
a week before i'm at morgan standing 9
10. so this is 9301 how old am i 9301 22
years old okay
i got an mbna credit credit card i go to
las vegas i said screw this i want to
make some money
so my mbna card allowed me to take out
five thousand dollars
cash so i take the whole five thousand
dollars uh oh i go at the table
paying 20 something percent and this is
at a time where
i'm sitting there i'm wearing this tank
top i'm just like
chiseled i'm in great shape and this is
the greek goddess this is the greek
god day and the cashier says cashier
mistaken mistaking me for somebody else
saying are you here for the uh
for the uh what is it vivid convention i
don't know what it was are you here
today aviana convention yeah
i said i said what do you mean it says
are you here to because are you one of
the actors
are you right yeah that's nominated
actor of the year
so he brings the other guy yeah i know
you finished second so so
they're doing all this stuff and we're
having a lot of fun together and then i
said
guys i'm gonna make 30 grand today
period
i take the five thousand dollars ask me
how long it took me to lose the five
thousand dollars yeah what five minutes
thirty minutes
yeah gone by the way five thousand
dollars may not be a big deal to you
right now it's a big deal
22 you got a thousand dollars in your
bank account savings
you have nothing else you don't have a
four wink you and you put 5 000
k it's insane and you leave and you're
like
at this point of the game i got nothing
left i got aged 22 22
years old and i'm going back and i'm
gonna go back into the army this is a
screw it i'm going back to in the army
on the drive back i get the call saying
dave
kirby has offered you a job at morgan
standing dean witter
i said you got to be kidding me i
started a week after i lost five minutes
and then luckiest let me tell you what's
going on with the call i kind of need a
job yeah
it's like listen i honestly have many
options right now but you know what i
will take your job because i want it and
then backing out you're like no
i desperately need a job right now to
make up so the point is this look
when you're younger if you want to do
some stuff great don't make the big
stupid mistakes that you're going to pay
a price for
20 years you're going to make a mistake
you're going to pay price for the next
three to six months whatever
not the 20-year type of mistakes but
long-term if you're investing long-term
you don't have a lot to worry about so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you